good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone is having an amazing
splendid chugalicious day
you know what i'm having all those
things so far and more
because i rose and grown this morning
and i did a workout before the toast
that's
two in one week that's crazy isn't that
crazy i'm
actually going i'm going for a two a day
today because i'm going to live method
later and i was like i wanted to get
some cardio in because i'm
i'm in grind mode sometimes you're on
and sometimes you're obviously right now
i'm grinding
sometimes you're in rise mode and
sometimes you're in grind mode right now
i'm in grind mode for memorial day
weekend and i'm doing a two a day today
and i will let everyone know how that
goes so happy for you
because i was really inspired by the
kardashians because they do
kylie's been doing two a days and i'm
like i could try it two a day
that's so funny i'm doing two a days two
maybe two lunches and two dinners
and i just feel like that's really gonna
bring me peace self care looks different
for everyone 100
we love to see it you know what it looks
like for me yesterday posted up on the
couch listening to the amazing playlist
you made from our nashville trip just
like of all the songs we like heard and
liked
and i read some random colleen hoover
book called ugly love and it was
so cute like i was obsessed i finished
in like three hours and that's how my
evening was because ben was out and it
was honestly i don't like being alone
but it was like peak loneliness you're
never alone when you have a kindle
there's worlds waiting for you you're
also never alone when you're with christ
that's true i've heard you're never
alone when you're with ceo
well that actually is true yeah and you
were with theo
so you weren't actually yeah of course
no i'm not i'm really not alone when i'm
with theo but i forgot to tell you this
yesterday thea was a tbt
a two breakfast tigs we love the two
breakfast tigs
when the parents don't communicate every
now and then
we got a tbt situation because
me and ben woke up fed theo bends in the
shower i go in to brush my teeth and i'm
like i fed theo
he's like wait no i fed him at seven i'm
like seven we were asleep
and he's like no no like he got up so i
fed him i'm like what like it was such a
dumb
miscommunication 100 ben's fault so theo
accidentally had to breakfast yesterday
and he has been farting
all day like i read the whole book with
like a big fart up my nose like
permanently
he has been farting so much he just
farted like it has been so if you smell
anything it's not me it's theo
okay you know what i understand i
personally love it two breakfast tigs
like he thinks it's his birthday it's
like
so exciting so i'm happy for him that he
got an extra breakfast in
it's special it is special in the grand
scheme of things like it doesn't really
matter
no and he just felt really special and
and we love that for him i wonder if he
knew he was tricking us or he was just
like wow they're being so nice
if he was like no mom i'm good yeah i
already ate
thanks i'm all full i'm also i'm all set
thanks mom
um so what's up like what's going on
with you nothing much i really am just
like
in grind mode you saw me yesterday i was
taking calls from the treadmill which
was just like such a crazy thing to do
but i i really um enjoyed it like two
years ago i heard skinny confidential
say that you should like
take like do your emails from the
treadmill i was like that's a good idea
and then finally two years later i put
it into practice
sometimes these things take time
sometimes they do
and then again like couldn't tell you
what i did yesterday but it was a very
busy day
it was we had a really big meeting about
our merch we've got some sickening ass
merch coming up
so many collections honestly so little
time so little time but make sure you're
being kept abreast at
shopmorningtoast.com oh yeah then i went
to olivia she cooked dinner very
delicious
good times i saw um thanks for the
invite well you saw them on sunday
thanks for the invite
well my home was not ready for so many
people since bruno peed all over it
you were making that up i actually spoke
to him and he said that you made it up
oh yeah i
made it up yeah the piece in the
elevator i actually peed myself
i dropped trowel in the elevator and
peed and blamed it on brew
i dropped trowel on my own bed twice
that sounds like you pretending
it was theo and then one last time for
good measure on my living room carpet
that sounds like you love to see that
you're hydrated no it's good it's good
yeah
keep lining yourself keep lying to
yourself no no keep lying to
yourself bruno's a gem but he's
such a sweet boy but he you know
he's going through something i think oh
you think i think he's just feeling a
little lost
you know just without direction
i think that is what it must mean he's
at a pivotal place in his life where
he's like
shall i be a good boy or a bad boy and i
know he's gonna pick
good boy but i think he's flirting with
the bad side
two roads diverged in yellow wood and
brew took the road less traveled
yeah he will of course be a good boy
because i know that's what's in his
heart but he's flirting with the dark
side
it's so important he's having you know
what he is he's on his rump springer
he is he's on this rump springer he
doesn't know if the amish life is for
him so he's heading out for a couple
days to see the english world
dance with temptation and then come back
so you could be a good amish boy
i know and you know what if you love
something set it free if it was yours it
will return
and if it went on rum spring it's
probably not coming back no i know he's
breaking bruno but he'll be back
breaking amish was such a good show
breaking bruno and i
feel like not enough people talk about
kind of
the evolution of the tlc network because
now it's like a circus
it's like i don't i don't like what it
is now but there was a time
when they were churning out such
unbelievably sickening programming
sister wives it was still circus themed
yeah but they took it too far now like
some of the [ __ ] they have on there it's
too far okay but like it was always like
meant to be
like show the circus channel yeah
literally tlc
the last circus like 100 i just feel
like where it's at now it's like taking
it a little far
but um well they were obviously so um
successful emboldened by their early
success
well all i'm saying is that i feel like
i'm not enough people speak about like
early to me no like 2010s
there was some unbelievably sickening
programming going down on tlc in a good
way
that's great and now it's just sickening
like that dr pimple popper show
is so disgusting sick sick
well other than that it's quiet times
i watched real housewives of new jersey
last night so we'll recap that whenever
but i'd like to remind you it's on
wednesday and i got back to it so i'm
catching up on everything
and yeah i'm enjoying my book i got to
read a little bit yesterday i had a
migraine for the last three days so i
couldn't watch tv or even read that's
when you know it's bad i just had to
like lie in the dark yeah
so i'm back on my content grind plate is
full feeling bountiful
plate is full though low sodium and
that's it's bountiful
we have um real housewives of new york
on tonight correct yeah anything else
uh no but i do feel like i'm behind so i
got to watch dynasty i'm so excited
i got to keep up on keeping up so i'm so
behind on keeping yeah so i'm
not keeping up i have a lot ahead of me
including my two a day i'll let you guys
know
how that goes i wonder if i'll be able
to make it all the way but you know what
life's a climb yeah and the view is
great but you got to try new things you
got to push yourself
you want to see that change you sound
like a soul cycle instructor
i know that's probably where i heard
that but i think it's true what was the
phrase like you have to push yourself if
you want
change because if you want to if you
want something new to happen you have to
try something different
i guess for sure it's not like life's
not a colleen hoover novel like crazy
things don't just happen to people who
are doing nothing
exactly you know that's literally the
premise of every single colleen hoover
book
yeah no it's a terrible example i loved
ugly love by the way i highly recommend
sweet and i'm reading the romanov
empress the story of maria
theodorovna very good so far
i can't wait to read it next yeah i'm
gonna gift it to you oh
that's so sweet you should be able to
give someone a kindle book like
oh that's cute yeah that's a cute idea
okay
okay well without further ado
here are the fast side stories that dude
needs to know and you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
hair food hair food offers simple
superfood inspired products that will
make your hair look and feel amazing
whatever hair texture or hair type you
have hair food has a recipe for you
in addition to their beloved nourishing
coconut milk and chai spice collection
you have to try some of their new
recipes like the apple cider vinegar
herons
which is perfect for days when your hair
needs a gentle cleanse before
conditioning
the tumeric and almond oil detangling
milk takes care of the stubborn knots
and it reduces frizz
and you can also try the shea butter and
pear color repair concentrate
it makes over processed hair look
vibrant and healthy they all smell
really really good and every product is
free of sulfates parabens dyes
mineral oils and they are certified
cruelty free by peta
so if you're looking for nourished
healthy hair it's got to be hair food
trust and believe the detangling milk
will change your life
detanglers not just for children so you
can look for hair food at amazon walmart
and target if you're looking for
nourished healthy hair
it's got to be hair food available at
amazon walmart and target
love it sign on feature hair
first story big news ariana grande is a
married woman tmz has learned she tied
the knot
this weekend sources with direct
knowledge tell tmz the wedding went down
at her home in montecito
tmz is told there were less than 20
guests including family members from
both sides and the whole thing was very
intimate and filled with a lot of love
we're told there was no real ceremony
she and her fiance dalton gomez said
their ideas in an
informal way it was really just for them
it's unclear how long they
plan to do it in this way in other words
whether it was impulsive or not or if
this was always the plan for a small
lethal wedding i literally forgot that
she was dating this random man
and that she was even engaged to him um
cute like not how i would do it if i was
ariana grande but
cute yeah i found this really surprising
because i feel like
ari she's been engaged before and like i
s like now she's a married woman like
everything's changed like this isn't
just like another like
ari's in love and god rage like ary's
married
yeah no and it kind of like washes away
all that
happened before this it does like now
this is you know
day one fresh afresh day one husband and
wife
it's crazy it's a new era um i'm
curious if they like had a wedding
planned and like just decided to do this
like informal ceremony
because it's one thing to do it really
private with 20 people but it's another
thing to like not even have a formal
ceremony it's like
yeah did they get married yeah they got
married but no but like there wasn't you
know
the caterer the photographer got it like
the
classic wedding things what do you think
do you think she wore her hair in a high
pony 100
because that's her look and why wouldn't
she want to look her best on her wedding
day yeah i agree
i i do hope that one day soon we get
pictures i would she's
such i think personally like style
icon queen and i would love to see her
wedding look
yeah but if it was as formal as informal
as
this article says like she probably is
wearing sweatpants no but she's also the
kind of person who like gets dressed up
to go to the grocery store
so i think if it's her wedding i i think
she wore like a little
white dress thigh high boots and a high
pony i do think so oh you think she had
the boots
i think she had boots i think she wore
like you know how my dress was like
tool-tiered
yeah but only one tier only one tier of
tulle like so like like what she wore
on jimmy fallon when she was promoting
pinterest
a little pink dress in white yeah with
white boots
and a high pony half up half down
probably because you should look and
feel like yourself on your wedding day
so if that's the case then that's great
yeah i think i hope we get pictures and
if i were a betting woman and there were
bets placed on these sort of things they
definitely are
that's what i'm betting okay i don't
think we'll get photos
i don't know maybe in a like a music
video or something oh she comes out with
a song
yeah like i do literally very jessie
james decker
very did jesse jim jerker do that she
wrote a song called i do for her wedding
she performed at her wedding and then
the
music video was wedding footage and
honestly she posted it recently i guess
they had an anniversary and
i had chills it was so good honestly i
would say one of my biggest regrets is
releasing toast after my wedding so that
i couldn't perform my own song at my
wedding and swing myself down the aisle
yeah well you know what they were so far
apart like literally four years apart
that that's not even something
you it's not in the realm of possibility
so why bother
yeah regretting it don't was so it was
so beautiful and those boys who sang you
down the aisle did it better
than you ever could 100 no offense 100
so i'm really happy for ari this is some
unexpected news that we love to see
yeah i'm just feeling very negative
this week like okay i was recapping like
our episode yesterday and i was just
like i said i hate bill gates i hate
olivia munn like
i was just feeling negative and maybe i
do feel that way i'm just like in a
negative headspace
or conversely like maybe everyone just
[ __ ] sucks
you know what it is sometimes that i
hate everyone everyone is annoying me
like literally everyone
but i think that's on them being
annoying and not you being annoyed i
think it's definitely a little bit of
both like i'm definitely in the toxic
head space right now i'm just like
really aren't i like just this is who
you marry like like sorry
like i'm just like great you know i'm
just feeling negative and i don't want
to bring down you know people who are
happy about this news so like whatever
but that's what you can always get here
like at the toast like if you're ready
one way about justin hartley i might be
feeling the other
negativity no balance yeah no balance
i'm just like feeling negative so
when i don't have anything positive to
say i don't really have much to
contribute
i understand well you know what it's
just like show us pictures show us the
pictures
i think other people are feeling
negative i think we're all feeling
negative sometimes
and i think that your negativity
represents a lot of people sometimes you
know i think it represents
the fact that it's 1 000 degrees in the
studio and i'm about to faint
yeah and it's so hot outside i'm just
like not really emotionally ready for
summer and it's been made abundantly
clear to me by the weather today that
like summer has arrived
summer summer summer summer also i
watched the first episode of high school
musical the musical the series season
two
it was like so bad um i i just have a
feeling that it's bad i'm not even gonna
add that to my
plate cause like it's obviously weird
with the olivia and josh of it all but
it's also just like
not good like yeah like scripted like it
was just not good
understood i feel that um anyways back
to being negative like
do what you got to do sometimes
self-care looks like being negative that
is true
you know yeah um and then i'm gonna slip
in another story about someone who i
know you don't
feel good about speaking of negativity
speaking of negativity dominic
west's wife reflects on their wonderful
love affair
after the lily james photo scandal wait
what so dominic west and his wife are
together
she is reflecting on their beautiful
love story as if
the lily james thing has not happened
and open celebrities or i don't know if
i can call this woman dominic west's
wife a celebrity
um i just love when they think we're
delusional you know like we remember
and that's literally the only thing
we're going to remember until the end of
time
dominic west's wife katherine fitzgerald
is feeling nostalgic at the beginning
days of her relationship
with dominic she spoke about her love
affair with west whom she first met
during their days at trinity college
dublin in an interview with the irish
independent published sunday
she did she admitted that her marriage
has faced ups and downs amid the media
storm that began after he was
photographed with lily james
she told irish independence she had an
instant attraction to dominic when they
met
also you know what it's just like
literal propaganda 100
you know what i just realized i just
really want to talk about dominic west
because what
i learned like not only is he going to
be disgracing us
in the affirmative in the crown horrible
worst show ever
in the crowd next season he's also going
to be in the next
downton abbey movie the sequel movie and
you know who else is in that movie lily
james
and i don't even think that's where they
met how did dominic west like get in
with the british crowd like to play
a role in the crown and in downton abbey
he's not that good of an actor
i don't know and i'm upset about it yeah
i'm also upset that like
so far i haven't known any of the actors
or actresses who've been on the crown
which kind of make it like it's an even
playing field like i don't know you from
anything you don't remind me of anyone
but dominic was a character on the
affair which i did watch all six seasons
of so i don't really like that i have
this familiarity with him
um when i just like like leave this
alone like
let's leave dominic out of this you know
yeah let's leave dominic out of this
though the update here is that him and
his wife are still together despite the
fact that he was spotted in rome like on
a trip
that was like a crazy time yeah they
were like spotted once and then never to
be seen together again and then she was
also spotted out with like chris
one of the chris's yeah yeah like
one of the i was gonna say something
mean but i'm not okay that's nice you
know what i will
no i won't okay but also i just want to
just sneak in a tidbit about another
person that you don't like justin
hartley confirmed
is married to his girlfriend that girl
now wife yeah
so like when they show up to the award
show wearing wedding bands let's just
assume they're married
what is with everyone being like so coy
like
like no i feel like they weren't being
coy at all and it was just like
the media didn't get the memo like
because it wasn't like spelled out for
them because they're like irrelevant
yeah yeah
yeah so they're like they are wearing
wedding bands yeah so they had some
boyfriend and girlfriend are wearing
wedding bands yeah that's fair that's
fair
you know but we sniffed that one right
out yeah uh it wasn't not hard
too theo did it he's the one who told me
the thing with dominic west
is is he even british that's what i want
to know
because he was american in the affair
which of course could have just been an
accent
but there's no way he's english okay
english because there's no way they
would let an american disgrace
themselves in the crown they wouldn't
they wouldn't do that it's such an
authentic show
so authentic who's he playing in
charleston grown charles which is
actually pretty good because we already
hate him
yeah and obviously we're going to hate
grown up charles if it if younger
charles is
any indication 100 so it's it's not the
worst thing but this downton news
just a tough blow it was a blow for the
downtown stands
uh i'm so excited for the crown i'm
excited
just got the most recent like diana
season
yeah not the woman you married
don't bring the boys into this are you
ready for our next story
i won't bring the boys into it i promise
thank you yeah i'm ready okay so a
little programming news
wait a little programming news that's
brought to you by if my calculations are
correct
by zip recruiting yes that's the one
if you're a business owner who's hiring
you probably face a lot a lot of
challenges
when it comes to finding the right
person for your role and that's why
hiring can feel like trying to find a
needle in a haystack
sure you can post your job to a random
job board then all you can do is hope
that the right person comes along
but that's why you should try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
toast when you post a job on
ziprecruiter it gets sent out to over
100 top
job sites with just one click then zip
recruiters matching technology finds
people with the right skills and
experience for your job
and actively invites them to apply in
fact ziprecruit are so effective that
four out of five employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the first day
it's no wonder over 2.3 million
businesses have come to zip recruiter
for their hiring needs
so while other companies overwhelm you
with way too many options zip recruiter
finds you what you're looking for
the needle in the haystack and right now
you can try ziprecruiter for free
at this address ziprecruiter.com toast
once again make sure to go to
ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t zip recruiter the smartest way
to hire
love it so here's our programming news
nbc's 2021 to 2022 schedule
has no comedies nbc is loading sounds
like they're looking for a rising star
in comedy
nbc is the negative outlook on life on
its fall 2021 schedule with so much
drama it's not even funny
literally like literally i thought that
was good it's cute it's cute i'm just
being negative
literally for the first time in at least
50 years the network will start a season
with
no half-hour comedies on its schedule
nbc is instead saving return shows
keenan mr mayor young rock
american auto and grand cru for early
2022.
you know what's kind of crazy though
like all of those shows that you just
mentioned like their comedy roster like
are not popular
yeah or they're new keenan is brand new
and they literally do not give him one
dollar to promote it because they saw no
commercials
except one during snl like a year ago
like yeah they
there was no marketing budget what were
the other ones mr mayor i think that's
ted danson
yeah never like you know what i think i
speak for a lot of the people like we've
had enough of ted danson like yeah go to
yeah
we've all seen curb yeah no it's just
like it's enough
he was the good place enough let someone
else get a tv show
young rock come again young rock which
is the story of young the rock
oh yeah yeah i'll allow it and then
first year series which haven't even
premiered yet
american auto and grand cru both which i
have they literally sound like i haven't
heard anything about and i shouldn't
have because they're not premiering
until 2022 a video game grand theft auto
but that's really crazy that there's no
comedies
well they're so obsessed with chicago pd
chicago
svu organized crime like they have one
show and they give it 11 spin-offs
you know that's all it is in the fall
which is crazy for the first time in 50
years
i feel like abc really nails the comedy
genre
they have like the goldbergs black-ish
yeah
what else i don't know if anyone really
nails it
this is gonna be like a crazy thing to
say i just feel like
comedy sitcoms are like a little
outdated the format is
because of the way that people watch tv
now
um but you could say that about these
drama shows too
no i don't feel like they're outdated
they're still so popular but it's like i
can think of a million
sitcoms that got one seasons and got
cancelled but there's like honestly you
don't need much to me
be like it's literally the murder dirter
like yeah
it's just like this formula that works
and i feel like sitcoms haven't worked
for a while
and some networks i feel like hbo really
kind of nails like how to
do a comedy like veep was hysterical and
it was no laugh track no awkward like
setups no fake set like
it just we're over that right or we're
just living in an unfunny time and
there's a
dearth in the comedy space a death
no i think we're actually living in a
really funny time like you do yeah like
there's so much to make fun of
but we're living in a difficult climate
right no i think yeah there's so much to
make fun of but like our people
no no are people being funny yeah i feel
like i watch so much stuff that's
intended to be funny and it's so unfair
people aren't being funny on cable 100
so but also that was nbc they didn't
include that saturday night live
oh no they didn't include saturday night
live but they're saturday
is ending their current season soon and
last week's ratings were a record low
really yeah the elon musk one or the no
keegan michael k
keegan michael okay olivia under ego
really i thought like
definitely olivia rodriguez would bring
the gen zers in i think they probably
just watched your performance on tick
tock like yeah
you know they don't have dvr that's
something ddrs
so chewy actually the more i think about
it maybe you're really not chewy like
you have youtube tv and you have a chain
on your phone
yes everyone look at this
shane shout out who gave that to you
shop jill and ally
it's really cute yeah and ali shapiro
wow sorry i'm in like a foul [ __ ]
mood right now
you know what i can't really put myself
i'm definitely getting my period
as long as you can admit it yeah we have
no problem no i like literally feel like
running someone over with my car like i
don't even have a car like i'm just in a
foul [ __ ] mood like i didn't sleep my
throat kind of hurts like
and i just wish i was in nashville like
that's be [ __ ] real why didn't you
sleep
you know when you like read a book and
like you're like in the book yeah or
when you're playing like a game and then
you try and go to sleep you're in the
game
i'm always i'm thinking i'm always in
gym i was in the book and like i was in
this apartment complex where like the
book took place and i just like didn't
sleep
oh i i understand that you were just
like in and out of it yeah and like ben
was like
all over the bed and like the like no
one had respect for my 50 of the bed
so i'm just like feeling really quippy
and i'm
not to be like not to set women back
like 400 decades but i actually think i
am getting my period
so like just excuse me i'm just like
feel like slapping someone today
oh and it's so hot and that really
always bothers me and i'm looking
forward to walking home and hope someone
shoves me so i can literally shove them
back
so [ __ ] hard okay get all my anger
out we have two more stories and one is
going to make you
more angry and then one is going to
cheer you up okay okay
next up u.s airlines may start this is
disgusting
us airlines may start weighing
passengers
well u.s airlines may also start losing
passengers
and i'm starting an airline called the
fat fleet
and we don't weigh you we just cross our
fingers and hope for the best
airline passengers in the us may be
weighed at boarding gates according to a
report that's so easy
we're talking you eat so much at the
gate no not even that like okay you're
traveling with like a new boyfriend
like i went through this experience when
me and ben were like maybe like
a year dating we took our first trip to
puerto rico
and we went parasailing and it was a
horrible experience we never went again
because we were like fighting the whole
time
when we were on the boat the guy asked
us how much we weighed and like
ben said it and then i like froze and
ben was like i'll turn around so you can
like i'm like no it's fine and like i
completely lied i was like 125.
and the guy was like no for real i was
like
125. he's like okay it's your funeral um
and then i was up there like panicked
because i lied about my weight that i
was gonna like fall into the water
so i just think asking people their
weight in public spaces
should be illegal yeah well i feel like
one this
reminds me of that episode of curb which
if you haven't seen where they're
chartering a place yes
and larry needs everyone's weight and
like susie will not
give her weight that is so true that's a
great reference but this is actually an
interesting
factoid like how we got here because
aircrafts are required to ensure a safe
weight before taking off
and factor in averages for passenger and
crew as well as cargo and fuel you need
to know how much
weight is on the plane in order to know
how much fuel anyway i understand the
math
but according to a circular advisory
from the federal aviation administration
in recent days airlines could be asked
to start updating average airline
passenger weight
to account for increases in the average
weight of american adults
after covid what was it like the average
weight gain was like 21 pounds for men
and no i mean it depends on like your
age but the average waking for
millennials
in covid was 40 pounds okay i'm below
average
yeah but we're also shorter so it's
still below
if you don't take that away from no no
i'm below average too but i think that
if you if you measured up average height
with weight like
it's per if it was percentage body
weight like we might be
those people no i don't think so um
anyway so like i it's it's an
interesting fact right it's a
sign of the times it's just really the
average
weight of people has gone up
no the thing is it's like build bigger
planes
or i don't know better planes like this
just sounds like a them problem
don't bring me and my weight into this
imagine like when you weigh your bag
on the scale on to hop out and they
already have systems in place okay but
what if like
okay i would do this if like i could
just input my weight before like in the
privacy of my own home okay but but like
some people would lie like some people
haven't made themselves in years
yeah that's true you know but i agree
like this is so
embarrassing no it's awful and like i
like to weigh myself in the morning
before i've had a sip of water like
what if i'm taking a night flight jackie
i'm just gonna become i'm gonna become
one of those people like travis parker
who takes a bus everywhere like i'm just
not going to be able to fly anymore
yeah i'll save myself a lot of money i
think that's the solution
it is what it is yeah i mean i
understand why they feel like they
should do
why this feels like the right move for
them i just
it's funny because like their priority
is obviously safety but like we don't
care i
literally rather the plane goes down not
know my weight i'd rather the plane go
down than everyone know how much i weigh
and like maybe i was the reason the
plane went down
yeah but i mean okay what if they weigh
you and the
the monitor only the
gate attendant can see it it's still
embarrassing i can't explain it
you think so yeah what is i don't know
this woman at all
but like that that kind of makes it
better if it was someone you knew like i
wouldn't want someone i know
to know maybe someone i don't know i
don't know it's like when you're gonna
wait at the doctor like that's not
personal that's just facts
no there's no good there's no good time
to get weighed
that is the takeaway here okay well just
want to give you guys like advanced
notice
and um we're all in this together you
know we're
all in this together
um are you ready for our fifth and final
story that's going to cheer you up
is it the final story
that's brought to you by yes it is
when we push our body hard or we're just
feeling run down it's extremely
important to take care of ourselves
with the proper vitamins and nutrients
excuse me
that's why liquid iv creates hydration
multiplier plus immune support
to maintain and strengthen your immune
system the hydration multiplier plus
immune support is a cutting edge blend
of vitamin c
zinc well mewn in convenient single
serve packets to help strengthen your
immune system
vitamin c is well known to protect your
body and support good health
zinc is the second most abundant trace
mineral in your body and it supports
immune cell health and function
and wellmune is a naturally sourced beta
glucan that's proven to help strengthen
your immune system
so each packet of liquid iv is bursting
with fresh natural tangerine flavor it
tastes so good
and liquid iv can actually provide two
to three times more hydration than water
alone so
if you struggle drinking water on a
regular basis like i do try liquid iv
it'll really save yourself some time and
torture because sometimes drinking water
can be tortured
um when you purchase liquid iv you're
also joining their mission to help build
better lives for people everywhere
because with every purchase liquidity
donates a serving
to of liquid iv to someone in need they
have donated over 4 million servings in
response to cobin 19.
products are being donated to hospitals
first responders food banks veterans and
active military the company has donated
over 10 million servings globally
get your liquid iv hydration multiplier
plus immune support in bulk at costco
or you can order online and get 25 off
when you go to liquidity.com and use the
promo code toast at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you get better hydration today
using promo code toast.liquidiv.com
love it sign on get hydrated fifth and
final
story
that's actually the perfect segue to our
fifth and final story because you are
being
ned schneebly and eighteen years later
after school of rock yeah
i noticed two kids from school and of
rock are dating in real life i saw this
on tick tock
shout out to the girl on tick tock who
discovered that she was making [ __ ]
headlines mm-hmm from her mother
was at martha marty may you're a queen
she
realized that freddie i think his name
was who was the heftier kid who was
interested
and martha who was the blonde backup
singer yeah it was like kind of boring
yeah she was friends with summer
yeah yeah but like i don't think they
really like i think there was some
competition between them yeah i think
they were like friends maybe their
parents were friends
they are dating in real life i don't
know for how long but they're dating
currently
they are dating currently which is just
a beautiful story about the power of
school of rock
um that marta and frankie are a couple
as indicated by their very cute
instagram posts together
honestly i feel like this is just kind
of a sign
that school of rock is really the gift
that keeps on giving like
i watched school of rock a few months
ago
and i had the best night of my life like
i've seen it on broadway like
it is really a timeless classic
and this just proves that and this just
proves that like some movies were made
for a greater purpose and like
not only did we get an amazing movie but
we got love you know and i would
i would say that like if these two get
married and have kids like those are
jack black has to perform at the wedding
or like officiate a hundred percent no
no if these two get married and like
jack black isn't even there like i will
cry no because they obviously don't talk
to him he has to officiate
and they actually have to have like an
acapella choir saying well if you wanna
be the teacher
of me while she walks down the aisle
yeah and baby you just better forget it
that would be so cute i would like die
to go to that wedding
no sane i'm sure they like don't even
like want to like be associated with
school of rock like they've
probably according to them like done so
much more with their careers since then
but they haven't they seem like the type
who are like proud of where they i hope
so
i mean freddie like got hot yeah and
like it brought them together i don't i
don't think they would turn their backs
on it i don't
yeah what's funny about that movie is
like and we talk about this a lot like
when kids are in
film and television like it gets to a
point where like some of them are like
in their like
there's every kid has like a weird stage
like looks wise like
bran stark went through it very publicly
on game of thrones that's turning into
one of my dennis's funeral things like
because i bring up brent stark all the
time but he like was still let everyone
know
he's such a cute babe on the show but
then he went through puberty and it's
like an awkward stage
so we saw him at like this really weird
stage and then by the time the show was
over he was like a full-blown man
also happened with the kid from modern
family yep
luke yeah he had a really weird stage
but then he was like cute and like he
had like
like a six-pack and stuff but like there
was a questionable
phase it happened so but it doesn't
happen to every kid because
i think manny from oh he's cute always
cute like grew up like very
traditional like linear you know but
sometimes
kids especially boys they go through
like their awkward stage where they have
like you know a furry lip and like they
have
weird teeth like their voices their
voice is cracking but and they're on tv
and like
it's really nice i see how they feel
it's my favorite thing to watch
but what back to my point was that i
don't think any of the kids in school of
rock were going through that face
they chose like a really cute group of
kids yeah not to sound like a freak
they did choose a cute group of kids and
also what's also cute is that caitlyn
who played martha
is an ob gyn ultrasound technologist
they both live in new york
and angelo ate just graduated from law
school his name is angelo
yeah angelo massagli wait oh my god
they're so successful so they're not
even
acting anymore no they're they're no
longer in the craft that's crazy can you
imagine like going to law school on your
first day like you sit next to freddie
from school of rock
yeah i love how they're both just so
normal
yeah i feel like that's a great way to
get out you know like as a child actor
yeah that's like a fun thing to do
as a kid and then like you find the love
and
i wonder how they reconnected i doubt
they've been dating since
no no but besides from miranda cosgrove
did any of those other kids become
famous
i don't think so i find that interesting
it was just about ned he stole the show
he really did and
honestly honorable mention for sarah
silverman being in that movie i didn't
never realize that mm-hmm um
well i could talk about school of rock
all day no i know same so i'm just
really happy for the happy couple
um and i feel like we had like a nice
range of news that you needed to know
yeah you know yeah so
that's what you need time i feel so you
needed to know it and
that is our show that is our show
thank you guys so much for listening oh
actually we have a very
special guest tomorrow so make sure you
tune in it'll be on podcast and on video
i think you guys are going to be really
excited yeah i think you're gonna be
excited we're gonna record
nowish so thank you so much for
listening to the morning shows the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the five stories that you need each and
every monday friday and youtube so
if you're watching this on youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast and we're
podcasting we found some spotify itunes
stitch your public radio i already cast
blocks all the places so where we listen
to podcasts find out this morning just
like the five star of you but i
beautiful stunning and smart we are
hope you all have an amazing incredible
beautiful standing and smart day yes
see you tomorrow for hump day bye